Hey Thoughty2 here.
The Roman Colosseum is one of the Earth’s
greatest monuments to humanity’s long and
rugged history.
From Verona to Pompeii and even in Africa,
amphitheatres were erected by the Roman Empire
to entertain the public in the most inhumane
ways possible.
Ferocious beasts such as lions, tigers, elephants
and bears would have to fight for their lives
against gladiators, who were usually slaves
and criminals.
Sometimes the animals would be made to fight
each other and of course there were the public
executions, a spectacle where criminals would
be tied up like meat and an array of wild
animals would feed upon them.
Out of these horrors grew a great need for
captured wild beasts and so was born one of
the most dangerous jobs mankind has ever performed,
“The Beast Hunters”.
A group of pioneering entrepreneurs who risked
their lives to hunt down and capture wild
beasts then brought them back to amphitheatres
all over the empire for use in the games.
Tigers came from Armenia.
Elephants, giraffes, ostriches, leopards and
hippos from Africa.
And bears came from Northern Europe.
Records show of a man who specialised in the
capture of wild bears whose name was “Ursarius”
literally translated as “bear-hunter”.
The hunters couldn’t use bows or spears
because of the risk of inflicting a wound
on the animal that would become infected.
The animal needed to be in good health, ready
to fight its opponents when it arrived at
the amphitheatre.
Tranquiliser darts didn’t exist then so
these beast hunters had to be creative to
catch their unfortunate prey.
One popular method was to dig a large pit
in the ground and stick a wooden stake in
the center of the pit with a dead lamb on
top.
The hunters would then hide and patiently
wait for a lion or other beast to come and
investigate the bait.
As soon as the lion jumps in the pit the hunter
would lower a cage from above, trapping it.
Another, more obnoxious method was for several
hunters to ride horses around the animal whilst
banging on drums.
The creature would chase the various horses
and eventually fall over due to exhaustion,
and so it could be safely captured.
Of course when dealing with such dangerous
predators in close confines, that haven’t
been sedated, accidents do happen and many
a beast hunter lost their life whilst trying
to catch lions and bears or whilst transporting
them back to Italy.
Surely workplaces have become more regulated
now since the days of the Roman Empire?
Deaths must be far less common?
Well that’s true except for a few extremely
high-risk jobs, one of which is one of the
deadliest jobs in the World today…
Welcome to the treacherous ship yards of Chittagong.
It’s a hive of industry and it generates
massive wealth for a few rich families, but
its also one of the most dangerous places
to earn a living in the world.
It’s a dark industry called “ship breaking”.
When their time roaming the seas is over,
ships from all over the world, oil tankers,
cruise ships, cargo ships etc. are brought
to the very tip of the Bay of Bengal, to their
final resting place at Chittagong, Bangladesh.
This is where ships come to die and so do
people.
Ships have a typical lifespan of 25-30 years
before corrosion takes over and makes maintenance
too difficult or expensive.
Now considering each ship costs roughly $1
billion to build, and they have to be replaced
every 25 years, that makes it an expensive
and very lucrative business.
Of course, when there’s hundreds of millions
of dollar’s worth of valuable steel and
other metals within the vessel’s framework
you don’t just want to let it sink to the
bottom of the ocean and slowly degrade.
So companies that own ships that have reached
the end of their useful life, send the dying
vessel off to a ship-breaking yard where it
is painstakingly dismantled, entirely by hand.
The salvaged raw materials, usually hundreds
of thousands of tons worth, are then sent
back to the owner of the ship so they can
sell it to all sorts of different construction
and recycling companies, making back a portion
of the cost of building the ship in the first
place.
And the ship breaking yard is paid for their
services.
That all sounds very well.
But the process of dismantling a vessel so
huge and dealing with such large, heavy pieces
of metals at great heights on a daily basis
is not only extremely perilous but often life-threatening.
In fact, ship breaking is so darn dangerous
that the whole industry was banned entirely
in the Western world by the 1980s.
Of course that left a huge gap in the market,
a gap worth billions.
One country where it still isn’t banned
to this day came flying into the market and
thus become one of the world’s largest players
in the ship breaking industry, Bangladesh.
Since then other Eastern countries have bitten
off a chunk of the market, such as India,
China, Pakistan and Turkey.
Today India is the world’s largest ship
breaker, followed closely by Bangladesh.
Yet despite the competition, the city of Chittagong
in Indonesia is world famous for its ship
breaking yard, but for all the wrong reasons.
It’s one of the most un-regulated and dangerous
ship-breaking yards out there.
Along with the deadly Alang ship breaking
yard in India, which happens to be the world’s
largest.
But why is ship breaking so unforgivingly
dangerous?
One of the biggest threats is falling metal.
Huge metal sheets are constantly breaking
off and tumbling down the sides of these gigantic
metal structures, many workers are killed
after being hit in the head or completely
crushed by pieces of falling metal.
There’s also a major risk of asbestos, lead
or heavy metals poisoning.
Asbestos in particular is an extremely common
construction material in older vessels and
workers commonly develop fatal cancers and
other illnesses due to the many toxins they’re
exposed to on a daily basis.
Some ship components are filled with deadly
gasses that can escape when dismantled, instantly
poisoning or suffocating all surrounding workers,
this has happened on multiple occasions.
And then there are the fires and explosions,
using power tools and blowtorches on a vessel
that likely contains a myriad of flammable
fuels, gasses and materials causes frequent
fires and sometimes devastating explosions.
If all that isn’t bad enough, many workers
are killed by simply plummeting to their death
after taking a wrong step atop of the vessel.
And for risking their lives, ship breaking
yard workers are paid a measly $3 per day.
But the West is not without its perilous professions.
One of the deadliest jobs you can do is lumberjacking
also known as logging.
America was built by lumberjacks, they felled
the trees that created the first houses and
the first towns.
Despite all the technology available to us,
the humble art of felling trees is still a
commonly practiced profession, especially
in North America.
However, in a recent study it was revealed
that lumberjacking or logging has the most
injuries and fatalities per 100,000 workers
than any other profession, except one, but
I’ll talk about that in a minute.
It was followed closely by fishermen.
Loggers are 40 times more likely to die at
work than any other profession.
So what makes chopping down a bunch of trees
so damn dangerous?
Well a good place to start is the 100 metre
plus, tall trees that are plummeting down
right next to you several times per hour.
All it takes is the slightest error in the
incision for the tree to fall in the wrong
direction, trees can easily kickback, launching
themselves right at you and barks can split
and splinter which can be deadly.
84% of deaths in logging are due to falling
trees or rolling logs.
Surprisingly only 16% are due to machinery.
Yet when chainsaw accidents do happen they
are often gruesome and fatal.
This x-ray of a tree-surgeon whose chainsaw
slipped and went into his chest tells a thousand
words.
But things have definitely improved from the
pioneering days of the early logging industry.
Before the widespread of electricity, sawmills
were powered by steam which meant they needed
a constant supply of water.
Thus they were often positioned down river
whereas trees would be felled further up the
river.
There were no vehicles up to this job, so
how do you transport extremely heavy and cumbersome
logs to the sawmill, for processing into more
manageable planks?
Why send them floating down the river of course.
Ingenious yet simple, this was known as “log
driving”.
But logs would often get stuck causing a large
pile-up, so specialist water runners known
as “water rats” would rapidly hop from
one slippery, wet, rolling log to another
and hunt for the log causing the jam so they
could free it up.
As you can imagine fatalities were frequent
among these “water rats”.
The current is ferociously strong and all
it takes is one wrong step to be swept under.
Whilst all of these jobs are inherently dangerous,
non more so than the statistically most dangerous
job in the world.
With more deaths per head than any other profession
on Earth.
What if I told you that there’s a job that
has an 18% fatality rate, compared to loggers
with a fatality rate of 0.13% and fishermen
with a rate of 0.12%?
That job is president of the United States,
out of the 44 previous presidents 8 have died
whilst in office, a staggering fatality rate
of 18%.
Four of whom were assassinated, meaning 9%
of US presidents have been killed whilst in
office.
And some people spend millions of dollars
and dedicate their lives to achieve this prestigious
yet frightfully dangerous job.
Proving once and for all that the bigger they
come, the harder they fall.
Thanks for watching.